kavier M calls himself the lion he
claims he has the strength to carry out
the reforms needed to get the country
out of its current crisis the farri
right candidate Promises to dollarize
the broken economy and fight inflation
by shutting down the central bank we
entered the 20th century as one of the
richest countries in the world today we
are at 130 and in decadence we are 45%
poverty 10% are living in extreme
poverty and inflation is running at
300%
m is a harsh critic of China and other
leftist governments including
neighboring brazils for many he's the
Argentine version of Donald
Trump mle says argentine's will have to
pick between the political case that has
ruined this country and Freedom the
values that are enshrined in his
political party the problem is that for
many people in this country his ideal
are inapplicable in
Argentina many believe believe he's a
threat to democracy Chief among them his
opponent Serio
Masa Masa is the current economy
Minister who promises to unite Argentina
and Carry Out necessary reforms to
jumpstart the country's economic
fortunes even the Wilding government he
has been unable to control soaring
inflation I'll give my skin and soul and
all my strength to build a country that
today remains a Utopia for all of us but
we can make it come true masa's campaign
has been highly charged because of the
ongoing economic situation and fear for
the radical reforms mle could carry
out I believe that with masassa we will
have our differences but we will be able
to go to the streets and hold protests
with mle we won't have that option
there's going to be repression and more
poverty BS predict a technical tie many
remain unconvinced on who to support in
an election that will Define Argentina's
future
[Music]
Al
bu make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from
aler